now I'd like to introduce today's
featured presenter professor Robert
Sutton Bob Sutton is a professor of
management science and engineering at
Stanford University he co-founded the
Stanford Technology Ventures program and
the Hasso Plattner Institute of design
also known as the D school he's a fellow
at IDEO senior scientists at Gallup and
an adviser to McKinsey and company bob
studies organizational change leadership
innovation and workplace dynamics he's
published over 150 articles and chapters
and written seven books
Bob's latest book is the
Survival Guide how to deal with people
who treat you like dirt his website is
Bob Sutton net and his Twitter handle is
that is at work underscore matters now
I'm going to turn it over to Bob all
right
thanks sherry great to be here and I
would like to welcome everybody who's
joining us this is going to be kind of
my first major presentation of ideas in
my book so I'm really excited about this
and so let's jump into it and what I'm
going to do is I'll talk for 25 30
minutes or so and and then we'll open it
up for your questions and so just keep
those questions coming and we'll answer
as many as we possibly can I love
questions especially difficult ones so
yes ask me the hard ones
all right so so let me give you a little
context about both the story and
retelling today and and the book that
I'm going to be talking about so about
10 years ago I accidentally got involved
in writing a book about workplace jerks
a book called called the no rule
and there were a couple strange things
about that one I never really consider
myself an expert on workplace jerks but
one thing led to another and things kind
of reached a point where I would go to
professional events to talk about
leadership or innovation or something
and people for example McKinsey
Consulting they would introduce me
is this is Bob Sutton he's done all this
stuff but really he'll always be the
guy so I got this kind of weird
situation and I kind of resisted writing
kind of a sequel to the book the reason
that there was pressure for a sequel
besides the fact that the first book
sold well so they always want a sequel
is that the first book really focused on
organizational cultures how to build an
organizational culture that was a
relatively civilized workplace and but
the response to it was just about
everybody I ever met in a cocktail party
my barber professional events
journalists cuz I talked about a
journalist and I got an eight thousand
emails that all essentially asked the
same question which was help I'm dealing
with an or a bunch of them what
do I do and the range of these things
was unbelievable for example a Costco
worker who had who had jerky had a boss
who was a jerk another example of
somebody who who was a jerk was was a
local CEO who described bored holes and
douche boards who were driving him crazy
I had a Baptist minister write me about
mean parishioners and what to do about
it
and and then a lot of questions about
clients and they kind of went over and
over again and and so what I do I worked
on other stuff such as leadership and
scaling and innovation stuff like that I
kind of keep a running folder of all
these different emails and I said well
maybe I'll get to him someday and and
just to give you one more sort of
example so here's the cartoon so one of
the fun things we did for this book is
we had this cartoonist David Wilson
who's actually a political cartoonist
for a newspaper in Florida and so he
drew some cartoons based on the new book
the Survival Guide and had this
and I had this guy write me an e-mail
really long email about how he spent
seven years working for what he what he
called an $8 dollar hole factor factor
an factory where there was just
me
this everywhere there was a mean owner
he described oh he had he turned mean
and he had trouble sleeping he had
physical health problems he had trouble
with his relationship with the
significant people in his life and and
one of the favorite scenes and this is
one of those weird things that jerky
people do is they're weird about food so
the picture there is what would happen
is that the owner would walk up to him
and stick his hand into his bags of
potato chips and just eat them without
permission so that's it so these sort of
questions and stories that I would hear
were kind of the focus of the book and
and what we're going to talk about in in
following 20 minutes or so are some of
the lessons that I've learned in this
adventure over the last decade to try to
understand how to address really this
one question because this book just
addresses one question in a lot of ways
I'm dealing with a jerk or a bunch of
them expecially in the workplace what do
I do about them alright so let me start
out and talk a little bit in addition to
this big pile of emails that I was
getting that that I was that I was
getting that over the years the academic
literature on all things
absolutely exploded over the years so
and if you do a search search engines
that are especially for a scholarly
research things like abusive supervision
abusive customers
bullying workplace victimization you can
see the list there it's just astounding
how much research there is that
academics have compiled over the years
and although and we might want to talk
about this in the QA there actually
might be situations where you
individually might be able to get ahead
at least for a little while by treating
other people like dirt so there's some
controversy there about what are the
conditions under which if you will
finish first there's not a lot
but the thing that comes through these
literally thousands of studies
is that if you are if you will if you
will in firing range if you're around
people who treat others with disrespect
in a demeaning fashion who are rude who
do backstabbing we can talk about some
of the main if you will kinds of dirty
work that jerks do it's all bad news
thousands of studies so if you look on
the left-hand side of the side the slide
the evidence for well-being that if you
are confronting especially over a long
period of time but even short little
snippets someone who leaves you feeling
bad about yourself like dirt anxiety
depression poor relationships with other
people in your family there's great
longitudinal studies even done in the UK
that show that people who have nasty
bosses have heart problems
in higher mortality rates so that's the
one side that for you it's bad and then
in terms of stuff that will might be bad
for your career and bad for your
employer less productivity more errors
poor customer service so what ends up
happening is if your boss and co-workers
treat you like dirt you in turn that's
if you will rolls downhill we'll
we'll treat clients bad as well there's
some great research in large chains of
fast-food restaurants that when the
manager who runs the restaurant treats
the employees badly they waste and steal
more food and turnover absenteeism so so
regardless of maybe these can these
conditions which we could talk about
when maybe being a jerk helps you get
ahead it's a pretty rare set of
situations and probably overestimated
it's bad for your organization and bad
for your health to be around people like
this so so that's a very clear message
from from the academic research one
other thing and here's another one of
these Dave Wilson cartoons that's also
important another way in which it's bad
for you is that if you are around people
who treat you with disrespect and jerks
it's a contagious disease it's
contagious disease in two ways that come
out of the academic literature one is if
you are around nasty people
you are likely to catch it just like a
common cold they can produce us in the
laboratory they bring in a subject they
treat him or her like dirt and they
bring in another subject in that turn
person turn turns into a dirt it turns
into a nasty person and there's also
evidence the breed like rabbits quotes
that there's this thing that the Harvard
professor famous Harvard professor named
Roosevelt Cantor she described it as
homo social reproduction that
organizations tend to people pick people
who are just like them
so literally jerks are more likely to
hire jerks so if you hire one or two
careful they will breed like rabbits all
right so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna start moving to the survival part
of the show if you will but before I do
let me give you a little mental
provisioning and something that really
I've learned especially over the last
decade but from the academic research
from talking to people are jerks and
honestly when I've been a jerk myself to
we human beings have so many
self-serving biases we're so bad at
seeing our weaknesses that including for
things like disrespect or that
that we're not very good at recognizing
when we've treated others with
disrespect or are consistently
disrespectful or nasty but on top of
that we're pretty quick to blame other
forces outside of ourselves so so if you
want a kind of if you will mental
provisioning a mantra as you're dealing
with managing situations where you feel
as if you're being demeaned the
energized
oppressed whatever I would swear to
suggest be slow to label others as
but be quick to label yourself
as one because you're by doing so you're
countervailing a whole bunch of other
psychological forces well-documented
psychological forces that push you the
other direction okay so here's my four
main sets of survival methods these are
chapters in the Survival Guide
so let's sort of jump in and and start
talking about them
first one the best thing you can do is
make a clean getaway if you are in a
situation it could be a customer we'll
talk about customers in a little bit it
could be a co-worker it could be a boss
it could be a Lord of the Flies
situation where everybody treats
everybody else like dirt doing the best
you can to get out as quickly as you can
is really smart and I've got Johnny
paycheck you may have heard the famous
Johnny paycheck song take this job and
shove it but my reaction is yes do this
but don't be stupid about it in such a
way that it particularly ruins your
career in your reputation and just one
little example I suspect many of you
have heard of is back in 2010 there was
a guy named Steven Slater who was
briefly an American folk hero so what
happened was he's a flight attendant on
JetBlue airlines and he has two legs
with a couple of really really obnoxious
female passengers who are just berating
him so he lands the second time I
believe was in Pittsburgh and one of the
folks who had been berating him one of
the customers she stands up early with a
plane still taxiing opens he overhead
luggage and he runs up to stop her and
he gets hit on the head really hard so
he's pissed and he's been abused by
these people for a few hours so what he
does is famously he gets on the
microphone tosses them all out called
tells them are all jerks says he quits
and that's where you see the slide grabs
two beers in fact activates the slide
and runs away from the airplane
and so if you want a made for media take
this job and shove it story this is
perfect but let's go back to the don't
be stupid about it he expressed regret
later
he got fired he got fine he was on
probation for a year so it's one of
those things that might feel good in the
moment and as somebody who has sometimes
has limited emotional self-control
I know it's often good to have a plan
and that's one of my general models and
mantras in the book too back to it's
good to have a plan is that I wish I
could just give you a formula or a
decision tree that
if you have a jerk if you do these three
things everything's going to be great
but unfortunately we all are in such
different situations that I can't give
you a one-size-fits-all solution so each
one of us if you will have to craft our
own Survival Plan based on what
we know and in consultation with people
who we know and trust all right so one
other thing so I'm talking about making
a clean getaway even better than that
is when you're going through the
interview process the job search process
any sorts of information you can get
that you are about to get involved with
somebody who's going to treat you like
dirt and be disrespectful it's really
important to look for of course you can
you can do things like read Glassdoor
online which isn't that reliable because
you don't know what part of the
organization you're going to end up in
socially positive gossips really
important if you have friends or people
you can get to friends of friends of
friends who work in the work group
you're going to go to that's probably
the best information and if you can have
some early meetings you might look for
red flags and just the example I'm going
to talk about so the reason I've got a
hippo there is if you think about hippos
nipples have a big mouth and they have
little ears so so that's one way in
which hippos are difficult to work with
also there's another meaning of hippos
some of you probably heard of which is
the highest paid person in the room and
then those two things usually go
together so anyhow this is eight or ten
years ago and one of my co-authors who
I've actually done a lot with it
Stanford masane first Center for
professional development and and we've
written books together and stuff huggy
Rao so Heidi and I had this potential
consulting client and we flew to Boston
for an all-day meeting and we're trying
to figure out how much to work with this
guy and his team so when this this
conference room for ten hours nine hours
one of those horrible all-day meetings
and the guy who was head of the group he
talked and he talked and he talked and
he talked and he only made statements he
never asked us any questions he talked
and he talked and it's about two o'clock
and
finally he sits that down next to me and
he was actually silent in somebody else
talked and he leans over and he looks at
me and he said it's the quote it looks
like I'm listening but I'm really just
reloading trying to figure out what I'm
gonna do next so after that meeting
huggy and I very quickly announced to
our client that we were too busy to work
with him and and I think that saved us a
lot of aggravation all right the next
set of approaches so if you're in a
situation where where you actually can't
avoid if you will working with for a
short or a long period of time with
people who are jerks
the way that I think about it is is that
Ness is sort of like kryptonite
all sorts of evidence that the closer
you are to this nasty stuff the more
frequent your exposure and the more
intense exposure the worse your physical
and mental health will be and also the
more likely you are to turn into a jerk
so this is my colleague Katie dis Ellis
it's actually her picture at CNN and she
on CNN and she visited Stanford a couple
of years ago and she studies all things
she studies air rage she studies
the relationship between prison guards
and prisoners she studies temper
tantrums by basketball coaches to see
the effects of it she so it was really
great having her next door to me and I
said to Katie some point working on the
book so Katie what's the most important
single bit of advice you have and I kind
of like her don't engage with crazy and
she means create as much distance from
crazy as you possibly can given the
reality of your life okay so let me give
you an example of something that I
learned from a former doctoral student I
know about how to limit the exposure and
this to me this is a really important
powerful method when you can't make a
full xscape and this idea of sort of
slowing the rhythm to reduce the contact
and in this instant world we're in we
get emails and texts and stuff all hours
of the night people can send them
repeatedly phone calls meetings and so
on and and what this doctoral student
did was she figured out as the quote
there says
that she had a batshit-crazy advisor he
would do things like holler at 3:00 in
the morning and yell at her and ranted
her writer repeated one email after
another after another often very
critical and often very hostile and the
and she's kind of stuck with this
dissertation advisors trying to figure
out what to do and she starts realizing
that for him and there are certain sorts
of especially maka valiant
who your if you will your pain
is their pleasure when they see you that
really long explanatory email they see
you suffering they see you crying they
see you squirming the pleasure centers
in their brain light up and this is the
kind of she was dealing with so
what she learned to do was to slow the
rhythm so if he called she wouldn't
answer it or she would answer every
fifth or sixth call if he said a nasty
email she'd wait for the next nasty
email the next ask email email and the
first year or so she'd wait a couple
days and by the time she finished her
PhD
she'd wait two or three weeks and just
send one sort of neutral email response
and wait another few weeks
same thing with meetings she would she
have the meeting stretched out first
weekly bi-weekly then monthly and in
this idea of slowing the rhythm is one
of the things that you might be able to
do within the constraint of a real job
another thing and I didn't put it in the
stack but it's really important there's
really great research that if for those
of you who work in an open office
environment if you can get a little bit
away physically far away from the jerks
in your office it has a huge positive
effect in fact there's a great long-term
study that was just published as
described in the Harvard Business Review
in places that shows that when people
sit within 25 feet of a toxic co worker
the odds they're gonna turn to a jerk go
way up and so are the odds they're gonna
be fired so trying to get that extra 10
or 15 feet will have a big effect
another thing that you can do to reduce
the exposure is to find a safety zone a
place you can hide where the
can't get you at least for a while and
the reason I
this crazy old David Wilson cartoon is
this goes back to that I was so long ago
I had a full head of hair this was like
in the 1980s this is a really long time
ago and my colleague Dan Dennison and I
in Michigan we were sending a group of
surgical nurses and were standing there
in the operating room an operating
theatre whatever and we're talking to
the head nurse and she describes this
doctor who had a history of sexual
harassment was a serious problem as she
describes it this female nurse runs down
the hall with this aforementioned doctor
grabbing her bun so she looks at us and
go see well a few minutes later her and
a number of the other female nurses went
into the went into the nurses lounge and
we tried to follow him in she put up her
hand you can't go near a stone nursing
room in the nurses lounge this is our
territory for safety so finding a place
to hide is can be useful use a human
shield this is what a boss is for if you
get a great boss what a great boss does
and there's research on one of the
functions management is to buffer
employees from disturbance and annoyance
if you can find a boss who serves as a
human shield that's another way to deal
with the so that's picking your
boss is really important and so this I
love this quote from a sports director
who wrote me some years ago I always
university sports director I always tell
the people who work for me the same
thing my job is to hold the umbrella so
the from above doesn't hit you your
job is to keep me from having to use it
so that's such a symbiotic relationship
all right one other thing that I kind of
got obsessed with is this notion that
when there's work groups especially when
there's sort of a jerky boss that some
friends there's early warning systems
where people formally and informally
create social connections to warn that
the nasty boss is coming or that the
boss is in a particularly bad mood and
I've gotten a lot of emails about this
and there's present stories in the press
but but a great example of this there's
an old not that old Sandra Bullock movie
where she plays a really nasty
the publisher who is despised by
other co-workers she runs run and yell
peoples and littles people and so they
had an early warning system and what
happened was so the movie was called the
proposal so what happened was that her
assistant figured out that she was gonna
be coming in busy another another
building another room so that's what the
email that was sent the witches on her
broom this sort of warning that if you
will there's an incoming ass so
sometimes those things can help alright
I think that's enough avoidance
techniques now let me talk about ones
that are really powerful for reducing
the negative effect of somebody who
treats you like dirt on yourself without
really changing the behavior
your situation at all so this is dr.
Aaron Beck he's the modern founder of
something called cognitive behavioral
therapy which is the most widely used
evidence-based therapy actually in the
world
and a lot of what happens in cognitive
behavioral therapy is rather than just
changing your situation you reframe and
essentially change your perception so
that things that are driving you crazy
and making you sick and making you
anxious you reframe them so they're less
upsetting even good things so so let me
give you a few examples that are kind of
loosely drawn from cognitive behavioral
therapy so one thing that happens in
congregational therapy is that you'll
recode the threat as less nasty
threatening upsetting and you did before
so let me give you a couple of examples
of where I've seen this in my work in my
research so one of the heroes of my book
her name is Becky Mar Giada batiste
magnificent human being one of the most
accomplished social activists I've ever
met in my life that the accident led a
campaign called the hundred thousand
homes campaign that found homes for more
than a hundred thousand homeless
Americans she's a woman who can get get
stuff done so Becky in the 1980s went to
West Point the US Military Academy she's
one of the
few women in the early days at West
Point and if you know anything about
West Point or in fact any military
academy there's a lot of hazing the
first year so Becky she's first year
plebe and the typical thing that would
happen I love the way she describes it
is that so it's nine o'clock in the
morning in an upperclassman upper-class
cadet walks up to her and gets an
intramural nose and says repeat the
major headlines of the New York Times
today this morning this is standard
hazing so she said you go and you try to
repeat it and of course to get it long
wrong and they'd scream at you and tell
you what an idiot you were one inch from
your nose so she said the first couple
of weeks she'd get all upset but then
she came up with the strategy of just
seeing them as these sort of brilliant
people who were really really funny who
really won't hurting weren't hurting her
they were sort of like a performance she
was walking watching in the theater and
you can see its idea of sort of not
having it be that bad and that's one of
the things that helped her get through
and she became very successful she was
involved in Special Operations had a
very successful military career bill
collectors years ago in the 90s I did
some anthropological research on
telephone bill collectors the people who
call us when you're late on your Visa
and MasterCard and one thing that we
were taught that we were taught when we
get a screamer or somebody you would
threaten us they'd yell at us a lot of
the whole culture was afterwards you
debrief with your fellow collectors and
they'd all say the same thing
oh that's nothing you should have seen
what happened to me standard sort of
solution okay that's one another one
what I kind of like is when some of
these nasty and abusive and art and all
the sort of stuff rather than this sort
of lesson lesson literally to which it
hurts you if is rather than getting
angry with him them feel sorry for them
and forgive them so some of the
expressions here is you say to yourself
if you've got a jerky bus
she's like a porcupine with a heart of
gold maybe there's some good in there
he's I heard this at Google years ago
he's like a guy with a bad user
interface but a good operating system
and the the key thing here about having
sympathy having forgiveness or somebody
who treats you badly even if you don't
change your behavior there's all sorts
of evidence that when you can forgive
people and have some distance it does
less harm to you because you don't
ruminate it you're not obsessed with it
so in some ways one place to blunt the
effect of an who even wants to
hurt you is to forgive that person
anyway okay another one which is kinda
related this is the Michelle Obama when
they go low we go high philosophy is
this notion that when people treat you
like dirt that you rise above it and say
you're not going to stoop to that level
and and when we're in the course of
doing the research for the book I ran
into a guy named Jacob Jabbar Jacob
Jabbar is a CEO of a coffee chain that's
mostly out here on the west coast called
spills coffee they're infiltrating other
places like Washington DC and the like
and they're really into this notion that
they make you this custom cup of coffee
and you have this relationship with your
barista take him calls it cups of love
and he said his perspective was our our
view is that if customers nasty to you
you throw the kindness back to them you
kill them with kindness so one of my
students I hired her and she went out
and did a bunch of interviews with
Phil's um coffee folks and sure enough
can see the quotes here their whole
culture was essentially to not to stoop
to the level of customers and to kill
them with kindness because acting like
that is beneath them so that's that's
another kind of interesting strategy
then two more to my favorite ones this
one probably is one of the strongest
evidence-based approaches if you're
dealing with somebody who's a jerk to
create some distance between you and
them do a little imaginary time travel
they call this temporal distancing
there's great laboratory based studies
that show whether it's something like
breaking up from a long-term
relationship having trouble with the
test that that people who think about it
in terms of how they're going to feel
about it a week from now a month from
now a year from now
rather than focusing on how upset they
are they tend to suffer much less upset
anxiety depression and so on and when it
comes to this is one of the
things that I would see over and over
again as a coping strategy and one of my
favorite ones I guess I'm doing a lot of
Military Academy ones is the guy wrote
me that when he attended the Air Force
Academy and he was being hazed because
we know this was part of the thing
you're being hazed he said he would look
past them and he'd imagine it was three
years from then and he was in his plane
flying and this was nothing to get
through to be able to have the privilege
of flying the plane and it worked for
him so a little imaginary time travel
can be very powerful
finally in a lot of what I'm talking
about there's ways to become more
emotionally detached and distance from
the person who is treating you like dirt
and they call these reframing sometimes
emotional detachment strategies they're
called all sorts of ways and you could
sort of see it in that Air Force plebe
trainee that I was just talking about he
would find a way to do emotional
distance but one of my favorite one
comes actually from a Stanford
administrator I know who is one of the
most serene people at dealing with well
I hate to admit it mercenaire at
Stanford around the table with multiple
people but we do have a few
maybe fewer than other organizations but
we got him
so anyhow so what this guy does I almost
use his name that would be terrible
and I I studied these people he doesn't
as he says he imagines when he goes into
one of these meetings that he's a doctor
who specializes in studying different
breeds of ISM of observing their
behavior of categorizing them and what
he does is the nasty when somebody is
nasty instead of getting upset he says
to himself I'm so lucky to see such a
fascinating specimen of this rare
behavior close-up and and it actually
worked so this idea of finding some ways
to distance and this person it's amazing
how skilled he is at this so that's
that's one you might use that I should
use but I don't because I study
okay so what we're gonna do so get your
questions in we're gonna talk for about
five minutes about fighting back
five or six minutes then I'll wrap up
and then I'm just dying to hear your
questions okay so if you were in a
situation where there are people who are
treating you like they're making the
decision about whether or not to fight
back or somehow another change their
behavior is something I encourage people
to do but with proper precautions and
some of the things you might want to
think about how much power do you have
relative to the person who you're at war
with if if you're the boss and have the
power to fire the it's your
company you have all the assets you can
probably fire them if it's a situation
where you're the boss after you they're
seen your powerful people after you
there's a powerful coalition in that
case you got to watch it and maybe you
might get more power by I'm causing or
by forming a posse of people but you
really got to be careful documentation
all sorts of evidence both for legal
reasons and and just for making the case
that the better document document ation
you have the better able you are to
fight back against that Gherkin just
just to give you an example of a recent
case a former Stanford undergrads I've
actually met years ago the woman named
gretchen carlson some of you men you
probably know this story she worked for
Fox News she also the reason I know she
was undergraduate as one of my students
was dating her and he and she became
Miss America so he did very well
understand for dating pool so anyway so
so Gretchen years later so she's working
at Fox News and Roger Ailes then the
president of Fox News is constantly
propositioning her in sexually harassing
her what she did was she got her iPhone
out and she recorded him hitting on her
and and making threats and so on so she
had very good documentation one thing I
should warn you if you are in the state
of California it is unlawful to record
people without their permission by
different you're in New York it's legal
and there's also options the harder you
fight back my advice is the more the
better if you can afford to not have the
job does you got other jobs lined up
that's great but if it's going to cost
you feeding your family or paying your
mortgage be a little careful
okay so those are some warnings let's
talk a little bit about different
different ways to fight back
one is and this is especially if you're
dealing somebody who is an unintentional
kind of I call it's clueless
rather than strategic who wants
to be good but isn't quite getting it
pulling that person aside and saying
you're hurting my feelings or you're
being obnoxious please stop so one of my
favorite examples this was actually one
of our SCPD Stanford executive programs
I was talking some about jerks and this
woman comes up to me issues an executive
vice president and she says to me so I
had this great incident with my CEO last
week where we'd have meetings would be
two of us it was two women four men all
executive vice presidents and what would
happen was and there's lots of research
on gender and interruptions the male CEO
was constantly interrupting the two
women never interrupting the other four
men so they carefully they they did
account they brought the male CEO the
evidence and said look what you're doing
you're being sexist he was horrified he
felt terrible about himself and he
changed his behavior in fact he would
ask them to count and keep doing it now
this is sort of the best possible
situation because this is if you will a
clueless rather than a strategic
but a lot of times you it's good to
assume good intentions okay there are
other types of jerks other types of
who well they're doing it on
purpose and they want you to suffer
I mentioned the Machiavelli and
those kind of people are in particular
research and Machiavellian is if you're
nice to somebody who's mock italian they
take it as a sign that you're a doormat
and they can keep pushing and and if you
got somebody like that maybe biting back
aggressively might be worthwhile and so
one of my favorite stories another email
I got is this woman wrote me about this
major she worked with he was a
retired US Army Major who was constantly
berating her in getting nastier and
nastier nastier until as it says she
gave him a hard stare very loudly and
told them that such a behavior was
absolutely unacceptable and he backed
off but a lot of it depends is you know
one of my mottos I guess is know your
ass
all the different require
different sorts of approaches here's
another one speaking of knowing your
so this is a CEO I met and I
can't name the company but he's actually
very proud of this incident and and a
very successful CEO in the 1980s he
built he was CEO of a company that had a
great IPO very successful all of you
would have heard of it but he was really
kind of a rough guy who was really tough
on his top management team and he had he
told this whole story he approved it
we've talked to other members of the
team this is fact-check and what what
happened was he had a pension for
vegetable insult so here's two of his
favorite himself you are dumber than a
head of lettuce and the average zucchini
could figure that out
okay so the sky unless his name keeps
insulting his team so what'd they do to
get back at him and send the message
will be a little more civilized so
that's the boardroom of the
aforementioned company in the 80s he
showed up and everybody's place was a
lettuce head with hats and sunglasses
that's his lettuce fed at the front of
the table they made up t-shirts they all
laughed about it but it delivered the
message to this obnoxious CEO that you
turn it down a little bit and he said to
me before I would start doing another
vegetable insult I would laugh and think
about the t-shirt I was wearing or what
happened that day
and it got me to calm down so I like
that story alright so one thing also in
many of the organization's you're in you
can use the system to defeat jerks the
example here because I was like to make
sure that I haven't I'm equal
opportunity of both female and male
as there's this guy or this
woman sorry captain Holly Graf she was
given a command of a very large Navy
Cruiser and was one of the fastest
rising young officers in the US Navy but
word kept coming out that she was
extremely abusive yelling at the little
ring hollering and swearing at and also
exploiting for exactly I think that she
had some of the officers mowing her lawn
and doing stuff like that and cleaning
her house do some stuff like that anyhow
so what happened was that it was
reported there was an investigation and
she wasn't
fired but she was removed from her
command and given less responsibilities
so that's the case where it actually
works I also do tend before we move to
wrap up is I wish I could tell you that
HR or even the law was your friend but
you've got to be very careful because in
many organizations HR is not your friend
and if you go to the system they're
going to protect a more powerful person
rather than you so knowing if you will
knowing the system you're in and how
much power the person has is really
important and in particular this is
something else I should emphasize
there's a guy named Gary Namie who runs
the workplace bullying institute and he
points out that it's private that it's
legal in all 50 US states to be an
equal-opportunity so if you're
being discriminated against or abused
because you're you're a woman you're a
minority some other protected class are
disabled you've got a better case but
even then if you go through a legal
process it's always important to
remember if you start getting to post
and everything very often they will drag
your name through the mud and even if
you win in the process you may suffer
quite a bit so so I'm a big believer and
yes sometimes you can use the system but
don't trust it completely because it can
turn pretty ugly and turn on you okay
let's move to wrap up my general view of
wrap up is that if you are dealing with
workplace jerks your job is to be part
of the solution not part of the problem
and and that's something we've all got
to take responsibility for and this
chart might be a little hard to read
there was just in a Wall Street Journal
article that I wrote but the key thing
that comes out of this let me give you
the headline when you look at national
surveys of bullying there's numbers that
don't add up about 50% of Americans
report that they have been victimized or
observed repeated bullying over time
less than 1% about 1/2 of 1% are willing
to admit that they have been the bully
so and this is back to this notion that
that we have very bad self awareness and
us human beings are very bad at
admitting we do things wrong and there's
great evidence
as of our lack of self-awareness the
worst way to figure out if somebody is a
bully or an is to ask them
because we have all have such bad
self-awareness the best way if you are
one or if you want to find out if
somebody else is one if to ask the
people around them and in particular if
you want to contain your inner jerk one
of the best things you can do is to have
close relationships family members
mentors co-workers who have known you
forever the people who will pull you
aside and tell you you are blowing it
you are not being so nice and one of my
favorite examples of great historical
couple Clementine and Winston Churchill
they were married for years and what
part of clementines job was to tell
Winston the truth and keep him under
control and there's this great letter
that one of my doctoral students Yocum
Ryan sent me
so it's 1940 it's the darkest hours of
World War two England's being bombed
this was around the period of Dunkirk if
you saw that film and so Clementine
writes this letter to Winston Churchill
which basically says you're acting like
a jerk Winston so I love this one of the
men in your entourage a devoted friend
has been to me and told me that there is
a danger of your being generally
disliked by your colleagues and
subordinates because of your rough
sarcastic and overbearing manner
my darling Winston I love the darling I
must confess that I haven't noticed a
deterioration in your manner and you are
not so kind as you used to be and then
by the way she went on with this whole
mini theory later on that if you do this
people will be afraid to challenge you
with the truth so I love that letter
okay two more one more quick thing and
we're there so if I would have sort of a
mantra it's this notion that it's on you
when it comes to dealing with
problems and you're not alone so what
you're doing is you're climbing a world
where you have to work with others to
solve your problems and to avoid
imposing it on them and so the reason I
have the picture of the two porcupines
there's a little story that ends the
book that EO Wilson wrote about it was
it was came to him from a friend of his
and what it described was there was a
cold
and there was a bunch of porcupines and
they were all cold and when they all
sort of slid close together and got too
close they poked each other and it hurt
that didn't work so then they slid so
far apart that they were cold and what
they did was they spent the night
getting just exactly the right distance
where they could have warmth without
hurting each other and what they from
then on called
that behavior was civility and good
manners and I kind of liked that because
we go back to the survival stuff
my perspective is that we all needed
each other we need to take
responsibility and we're not alone and
we're sort of like those porcupines
we're kind of shoveling back and forth
and every now and then we have to
understand we poke each other and every
now and then we got to understand we got
to get a little closer to each other to
help one another okay
so that's the end of my prepared remarks
I'm looking forward to your comments and
questions I'm excited to hear them and
now let's get to the questions
run okay let's start out we got some
really good ones coming in okay first
one what happens when the is
your boss okay so that's a hard question
but if you look at research on
who drive us crazy there's enormous this
there's an enormous amount of evidence
that bosses are the most troublesome
in fact the next person up the
hierarchy for all of us is the person
makes our lives wonderful or terrible or
both so a lot of bosses out
there 80% 75% of people identified as
and workplace studies are
abusive supervisors really high number
so there's lots of different strategies
that I've talked about in terms of how
much power do you have do you have a
posse do you document do you just need
to take it so so this is why you've got
to formulate your own plan but let me
just tell you about the evidence about
the best way to fight an boss
documentation and form a posse all sorts
of evidence good both anti-bullying
studies is the more people on your side
and the more documentation you have that
we get social support and if you just go
and complain about your boss well
I don't know if your gretchen carlson
you got the recording that might be
enough in the big time lawyer but for
most of us that's not going to work and
one of my favorite examples of this was
so this is a email somebody wrote me
years ago as an animal control officer
and they had a member of fellow animal
control officer possibly abusing them
swearing at them making racist comments
they go to the boss they complain
nothing would happen so what they did
was they formed they put together what
they called the diaries each one
of them for a two-week period just
recorded with dates all the different
incidents and all the horrible things
this person did as a group the five or
six of them went to the boss and then
that person was gone within a week and
that doesn't usually happen but there
you've got this idea of documentation in
a posse and a lot of it does depend in
the organization or some organization
where you can go to your boss's boss but
you damn well better know the political
environment that's a dangerous thing to
do in some organizations if I spot yeah
here's a good question many of our
participants work in distributed global
teams can you give suggestions for
managing jerks when you're not face to
face yes and in fact Pam Hines who's one
of our fellow faculty member she's got
an eye any one of our new executive
programs she's one of the world's expert
on this so everything I know about this
I've learned from Pam Hines so look at
Pam Hines stuff but here's what here so
here's what the research on distributed
teams and in fact even if you're in the
same big room and you're working on
slack all day and you're not talking to
people it's just as bad as if people are
in other countries by the way so to the
extent that you don't have I contact
people and you don't understand the
context they're in you are more likely
to have problems so the best thing you
can do and Pam finds is all sorts of
evidence if you're in a distributed team
expecially at the beginning of the
project if you can meet them even once
face-to-face before the project begins
that really helps in the other kind of
stuff that Pam talks about when you do
stuff that's distributed is it seems
like it's wasting time but it's not so I
don't know if you're in Germany you're
on a phone call with somebody from India
and and and then maybe there's somebody
in Chicago or something like that
take two or three minutes so there's
evidence to support this ask them where
they're sitting ask them what the
weather is like ask him what their
commute was like take a few minutes so
to humanize and to be able to get some
empathy for them but working in
distributed teams is really really tough
but it's something that we all need to
do and to go back to the slack example
or so many of us who work at home now
that almost all of us even when we in
theory all work in the same office or
office often essentially working on
distributed teams and the big morning
from the research is whenever you don't
have I contact and this includes the
telephone so what I'm doing to you right
now whenever you don't have eye contact
with the people you're working with
that's when people start getting nastier
and start having empathy problems okay
so here's a good question that actually
I'm curious about as well from reading
your book why are you so obsessed with
posits enablers oxygenate oh thank you
thank you so possibly more so I've got
this whole thing about I don't want you
to be part of the solution I mean part
of the problem I want you to be part of
the solution and and for all of us this
notion that it's on you and you're not
alone it's on us you're not alone but
what happens in organizational settings
is there a lot of people who are out
there out there in companies and the
private sector of politics and so on who
aren't but they clear the way
for them and they make it possible and
so my last book the no well I
actually had a chapter on the virtues of
and I had a set of guidelines
if you want to be an effective
make sure you've got somebody to clean
up after you sort of like after the
parade comes to town the people who sort
of like clean up the poop in the in the
paper and everything and it's old old
research by Peter frost University of
British Columbia he identified these
people toxic enablers toxic handlers who
after the boss would scream at people
after the boss would be abusive what the
toxic handler would do would go from
office to office and tell the people who
in this case he abused really he's not
that bad a guy he's not that mad he'll
cool down later and then the other part
of the top
to enable that they do is when the
says once I that bad the toxic
enabler since there's a lot of
ass-kissing involved in this says no no
you weren't really that bad and I talked
to them they're not really that upset so
what you're doing is you may not be a
jerk yourself but you may be enabling
somebody who is doing all sorts of
destruction and it's an interesting and
sort of weird role and as I said
unfortunately the other Simon if you
want to be a successful jerk hire
yourself a confident top plastic enabler
so I hate to bring that up but it's true
how do you determine if you're dealing
with a natural or one who's just
been created by negative workplace
dynamic this question this is this
question is sort of sort of made
or born there is some evidence that
people who were bullies in high school
go on to become bullies in the workplace
and they spend more time in prison and
all sorts of stuff but I'm actually I'm
glad you asked that question because one
thing I don't think I've emphasized
enough in this talk is that there's all
sorts of situations that turn almost all
of us into temporary and if you
look at modern life if you're in a
situation where you're rushed if it's
crowded oh it's hot if you around other
people who are jerky it's Oh an income
disparity so we're in this income and
status disparity and to me the perfect
analogy is getting on a modern airplane
with first-class and and and all the
different statuses of the United
Airlines which unfortunately I have to
fly a lot they have everything from
business class first class to the
absolutely you I think you can't even
put luggage in the overhead compartment
for the cheapest seats and and so what
they do is they create these status
dynamics and sort of a microcosm of
modern life so to me there's two parts
one is you may have some deep-seated
personality characteristics like
narcissism that makes you very thin skin
and very nasty but you just might be in
situations where there's just if anybody
would be a jerk and there's some great
experiments done with seminary students
so this is like these
people are training too you know to be
in the clergy and they put them in a
situation where they're in a rush and
there's somebody lying on the street who
seems to be dying with an arrest they
don't stop and help me because they're
in a rush so being in a hurry is one of
it was one of the most reliable way to
turn into a jerk but yeah you might have
personality problems but beware of
situations that can turn almost anybody
into a Dirk thank you so much Bob I
think we have a lot of questions we
weren't able to get to you can
absolutely see the value of getting time
with for experts like Bob here and we
just want to thank you so much for
joining us today we hope you enjoy the
hour and that you're better equipped now
to handle any jerks in your workplace
and we encourage you again check out all
of our offerings at CPD stanford.edu and
again it'll receive a recording of this
webinar to share with your friends and
colleagues we wish you a great rest of
the day
you